he is the greatest commentator in Combat
Sports period we flew him all the way
from Boca Raton Florida it's John annik
on today's food truck Diaries and I'm
feeding them Bagels let's go
[Music]
Mr John attic long time coming brother
so great to be out here we've been
planning this for a couple years finally
in the belly of the beast in Calabasas
going to be with you good to see you man
you're looking pretty fly well thank you
buddy I I dress up for you black is
pretty slimming so I figured I would
wear black head to toe we got the one
more sleep on the Mark Russell bomber oh
wow you know get your own jacket going
we filed for the trademark doesn't look
like we're gonna get it though it's
tough to get that's like one more sleep
that's like LeBron trying to trademark
uh Taco Friday right remember that when
he's trying to do that everyone's like I
don't think so dude and he also got the
the dope kicks on the ball ready
we had to bring it with the kicks if we
were going to show up here so I wish I
knew you were gonna rock those I would
wear my lower uh Rodriguez dunks those
are fire my man I don't think I'm like
hip enough to be wearing these shoes I'm
almost 45 years old I'm just gonna
[ __ ] fake it you might besides I mean
I feel like sugar Shawn O'Malley might
have dressed better than me on this show
but you're right up there
your top three we've been trying to get
on the show for a hot second you're the
busiest man in mixed martial arts you
you hold on you're the busiest man in
Combat Sports I don't think people
realize your schedule like I know a
little bit how the sausage is made in
the OC when I hear they're going to
Perth or wherever Abu Dhabi yeah you're
on the Marquis and you got to do the
commentary I'm like I always think Man
Poor John annik well I mean it's
certainly a labor of love but it's a
[ __ ] lot like I called the last time
I did a major college football game was
2015. and it's dude you blink it's half
time you get a 12 minute break and then
you go home it's like door-to-door four
hours versus 10 hours so I probably do
about 25 of the 41 shows a year that we
do but you know Mick Maynard and Sean
shell be giving us you know 30 Fighters
doesn't make things easier you know like
I can't even profess to you when I have
an 11 flight card 22 fights versus 15.
if you think about those eight Fighters
it's a lot it's a lot but uh I have a
pretty good system right now it's the
devil I know like if I had to all of a
sudden go do a full 17-week NFL schedule
right now I don't know that devil so at
least this is the Beast that I know but
it's a [ __ ] lot but if you could do
this Beast I feel like you could do any
Beast like the NFL beasts awfully
obviously different animal you could I
feel like do that pretty easily I also
think at this point you're irreplaceable
you're you've become like there's a few
people and you'll see that you just
can't replace it's you Rogan clearly
Dana White like you just can't there's
three guys there's three staples of the
sport you just can't do anything with it
well that means a lot coming from you
you know I felt like when Bert Watson
left and when stitched Iran left you
know somebody's always walking through
that door you know I think Bruce Buffer
is probably more Irreplaceable to me but
I appreciate you saying that because I
feel like I was sort of developed the
right way
I work basically for five years on all
the small shows I've been to Brazil 27
times so I got a real good depth of
knowledge for like the bottom half of
the roster and then when they called my
number for the title fights in 2017 I
was I was ready yeah so you started what
was it fuel back yeah fuel TV and FX and
my first call was January of 2012 and
then uh in 17 I started doing the papers
and you started you know with with the
kind of the undercard guys and by the
time you were at the higher level of the
main card all those guys kind of
graduated with it yeah so it's like a
perfect yeah it was cool khabib nurmago
metal made his UFC debut the same night
I was on the cans for the first time in
Nashville coincidence I don't think so
two greats but you know I didn't grow up
a martial artist like I've taken eight
Jiu Jitsu classes in my life and I
[ __ ] hated every minute of it you
know what I mean so for me yes I feel
like I could take a bong hit drink a
six-pack and call a football game
whereas with this it's a different
challenge for me now I feel like I'm
much more of a mixed martial arts head
an expert now than I was in 2000 11 but
football baseball basketball those are
the sports that that come easiest to me
for sure I mean especially growing up
Massachusetts I mean being a Patriots
fan obviously Red Sox fan you got Bruins
Celtics so it's like sports Run Deep
there but especially when you're coming
up to how old 44. yeah so I mean UFC MMA
was even the same yeah so it's like I
think most people are at that level no
one grew up being like yeah UFC is my
thing kids now right right at our age
there's nobody anybody who tells you
that's full of [ __ ] right I remember
watching UFC one in 1993 and then I'd
watch again until UFC 50 in like 2004 we
launched MMA live in 2008 but for me the
Turning Point really I was hosting a
boxing show and in 2007 Gary Shaw who
started Elite XC the longtime boxing
promoter he invited all this boxing
media to come to Tunica Mississippi to
cover that first Elite XC show henzo
Gracie and Frank Shamrock in the main
event and at that time in my life I'm
like defending boxing against this MMA
Avalanche like didn't like the grappling
didn't like the wrestling and then I
watched this MMA Show on TuneIn
Mississippi and I was like with respect
to the NFL this might be the greatest
sport in the world you know so my gear
started to churn that night in Tunica
Mississippi and I don't really like
watching boxing anymore all they do is
[ __ ] hold all unless it's like a
Javonte Davis like unless it's a really
big fighter who you know is going to
bring in boxing stuff I always say this
when it comes to boxing UFC there's a
reason why UFC makes martial arts in
general but really UFC surpass boxing as
if I set my six year old down and I have
them watch Boxing let's say it's a Floyd
Mayweather fight one of the greatest to
ever do it maybe the greatest I've
watched 12 rounds of Floyd or I have
them watch a five-round main event in
the UFC yeah which one do you think that
youngster is going to gravitate towards
yeah so that's boxing's issue right now
they need to figure it out no you're
right I remember back in the day I was
like I gotta have my family members come
see Floyd Mayweather in his prime and so
I flew everybody out to watch Floyd
Mayweather fight Sugar Shane Moses oh
yeah you know he got off to a bad start
so that was good and then he dusted
chain over the final nine rounds and I
felt like my party just felt sort of
underwhelmed by the whole experience
juxtaposed against now when my family
and friends go to a UFC pay-per-view I
mean oh they're probably chomping at the
business you're also one of the guys you
know you're you're one of the OG's now
let me talk about you know just getting
into it but when you were first starting
but you're one of the OG's now because
you were at ESPN bringing MMA to ESPN
before the UFC had this huge deal like
you and Kenny was at MMA live like you
and Kenny flooring had the show on there
I remember watching it yeah and you guys
were kind of like the rider dies for the
hardcores on ESPN because I was at ESPN
way before the UFC was there even when
they're on Fox and I'd be like the guy
breaking down like Kane verdum and all
that stuff and you'd walk around and you
were like this like they were like what
yeah but yeah you're here you're a [ __ ]
fighter it's like it's so easy no you
said that is a nightmare but you know I
remember you were like my favorite
fighter in 2008 because I was a football
fan and you were like the most
accomplished football player to ever
sort of cross into mixed martial art
time but yeah man we had to claw for MMA
right like red red-headed stepchild
doesn't even begin to destroy like
Stuart Scott was certainly helpful and
candidly I always thought he should have
been the guy hosting MMA live and not me
and had he been the guy who was hosting
that show I think that might have
expedited our progress internally in
Bristol it took us forever to get to
ESPN2 and even then you know we couldn't
show a lot of blood and things like that
but I gotta say man like when I left
ESPN in 2011 there were a lot of people
in my life in my inner circle who said
you spent all this time trying to get to
Bristol you're finally at ESPN and now
you're going to go do the cage fighting
thing and it looked like the UFC was
going to end up on G4 right I didn't
even care like I felt like that was the
wagon to hitch too I felt like the sport
was going to explode wasn't getting
football opportunity they give me like a
game a season you're not going to get
any better calling one college football
game season so now 11 years later like I
feel like I hitched to the right wagon
um but I don't know how things would
have developed if I had tried to sort of
stay on a more traditional ESPN
sportscaster path oh I I think you made
the right choice I mean you know you
could be you know there's a lot of Big
Time football analysts out there and
commentators and stuff like that and
guys who are facing the sport as far as
the you know the booth goes there's so
many of them but there's only one John
attic like I'd rather be the guy of this
huge sport than just one of the guys in
the other one now I don't know how
compensation works it might be it might
be better be the NFL guy in your 15th on
the roster as far as
calling plays or be the number one guy
in the UFC I don't know I'm not getting
your business there but what I do find
and tell me if I'm just off on this
there's you know there's a lot of
journalists who they failed at other
sports and then because the UFC was new
they were able to step their foot into
it there's also a lot of commentatives
and play play-by-play guys who for
whatever reason they just couldn't get
their foot into the door with the NFL
NBA MLB so that I I'll sell it for the
UFC is there any resentment there with
you because now that you're the the guy
and you'll see where you look at the NFL
or what other NBA you like told you man
well I look at some of the people I came
up with at ESPN like Molly Karam who's
hosting first take Cassidy hubbarth who
is their numbers sideline yeah right so
I do believe that I would have realized
some success and maybe would be calling
high level football games right now so I
think there's always going to be that
football tug but yes you're right like
being the lead voice of a sport is
something that I never thought would
materialize for me juxtapose against
being one of like 25 NFL announcers who
get a game or two or seven or 17 a
season so yeah I feel like I made the
right decision and obviously when I made
my first call in MMA and 09 I did
Bellator season one in 2009. I was
[ __ ] freaking out like I'm walking to
the octagon with Jordan retme I'm like
dude you got the wrong guy man like I
don't know what I'm doing but once I
don't know what I'm doing either but
once the event started you just sort of
play to your strengths you know it's
like I don't know what a Peruvian
necktie is at the time but you know I
feel like I have a pretty good
feel for the broadcast and when to shut
the [ __ ] up and when to talk when to let
the action breathe that's your gift and
I have to say like when I did Bellator
season one I just there's nothing like
doing Live Events what I don't like is
doing the studio stuff like I thought I
wanted to be a sports center anchor [ __ ]
that bro it's like all right top of the
fifth inning Athletics and Royals you
want to do that every night
that sounded good but I got to
experience that a little bit and I don't
want to do that every night like all
right we got A's and Royals highlights
top five get your jokes and while you
can like whoa doozy there you know over
his head I had a few liners there uh
when I would do highlights at espn.com
like I would kept go but release the
Kraken yeah see a doctor and get rid of
it I was I was so impressed when I
worked at ESPN is there wasn't much prep
like those guys they don't realize how
good those guys are at their job like
with me they're like okay you can go to
makeup like you got 20 minutes I'm like
cool but are we gonna go over like right
now
uh verdum Kane and you know the fight
yeah I know like so you're good you're
gonna have this spot and then you know
the host will be there I'm like okay
here we go and then I'd watch other guys
get ready and I'm like holy they're so
good they're such outliers I'm like oh
that's why you guys have this job right
like there's not much they're just boom
you are right and ESPN at least in terms
of their methodology they are much more
like flyby to see their pants on live TV
whereas Fox
is just much more I think trying to set
the table that's gonna happen so you
absolutely hit on a truth there and for
me I think it was good to cut my teeth
at ESPN like a lot of my broadcast
Partners their first indoctrination into
television was at Fox that is a talent
Network right that Network caters to
Talent like for me at ESPN I was putting
my suit on in a toilet stall painting my
own face until we got MMA live to ESPN2
and I think it was valuable for me to
grow up in that news environment so that
when I got to Fox I was like oh it's
kind of nice yeah you're like I got this
well I mean this could be a four hour
freaking food truck let me feed you we
have some yeasty boys Bagels now I know
you're not an LA guy but La food trucks
are fantastic my head producer Casey
swears by it so if it's bad blame him so
let me feed you some are you on any
weird restriction diet wise no no I'm
breaking my Carnival diet four years
it's where I do it for guests but I'm
doing it for you man I think it's been a
long time coming let me feed you some
yeasty boy Bagels let's see let's do it
let's take a little break from chatting
with one of my favorites on this episode
of food truck Dives with my boy John and
it cause listen it's a new year it's
here and you're making big changes
chances are you could use some sweet
sweet everyday earbuds from my friends
at raycon raycon's everyday earbuds look
feel and sound better than ever they
have the optimized gel tips with the
perfect in-ear fit look at these airs I
have tortellinis for heirs for all those
years of Jitsu and I can't just go with
any air but I need the perfect fit and
that's why I swear by raycon it's the
only freaking kind of little earbuds
that I trust they will not budge trust
me I use it when I'm riding my bike
working out the gym raycon gives you
eight hours of Play Time a 32 hour
battery life Recons are priced just
right you get quality audio at half the
price of other premium audio Brands it's
no wonder raycons everyday earbuds have
over 50 000 five-star reviews I'm
telling you these are the best earbuds
you've ever put in your little hairy
ears all right they have noise isolation
they have awareness mode but my favorite
is the freaking the way it fits in your
ear it's fantastic I use it all the time
riding bikes at the gym on planes the
only earbuds I use are raycon all right
so go buy raycon go to buy raycon that's
buy
raycon.com shop today and get 15 off
your raycon order that's byracon.com to
score 15 off raycon earbuds that's by
raycon.com shop now let's get back to my
friend John attic
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm not a good bagel in a hot second uh
what do you recommend what's what's the
go-to's for people
[Music]
sure
how good is this I'm not gonna fit my
suit in Brazil but no no I'm sorry man
no it's good
I feel like I should bang a bird man
because the same guy who did my 209
tattoo did all the [ __ ] Birdman's
tattoos you know the guy in the NBA
Chris Anderson yeah that's my boy yeah
he is great he's such a good dude I'm
gonna do a chatty WAP though if you
don't mind yeah because uh I just want
to get bad as [ __ ] right now yeah and
I'm gonna we're trying to turn you into
a thick boy dude let's do it fixing the
heart cut that's not a good slogan is it
it's not good it's not good these days
uh I'll do the game over
a little jalapeno smearing yeah man
spice it up uh I think that does it do
you wanna do you wanna make it heavy you
want a hash brown oh you can double fry
it adding a hash brown to make it heavy
I'm gonna hold off on me yeah me too I
don't [ __ ] my pants yeah I'll just do
the game over
Bagon cream cheese yeah I'll do the
regular bacon cream cheese
as well you have the cheddar jalapeno
let's do that
cheddar on cheddar that's good man make
it happen I appreciate you deviating
from the the keto caramel oh I got to be
careful man I'll blow up yeah yeah very
careful I like cut weight like when I'm
on TV like I just had 31 days where I
wasn't on camera I probably put on 10
pounds and like cut them off yeah when I
know I'm going on tour I gotta go back
so for the holidays I let loose yeah
I'll get to 275 about this really oh
yeah it's not fun my suits are just
tight like the weight Taylors my great
Taylor Mark Russ but the way these guys
want to tailor suits in 2023 they want
the pants up to [ __ ] yeah you know
and almost like the jacket goes like
stopping you
um but the suits are tight so I gotta I
gotta be like if I'm a pound over 55 I
can't freak out well Rogan too like
you're next to Rogan yeah I think he's
out of carb in like several years right
right so you're dealing with that Mania
yeah as well you got DC although DC is a
thick boy I look skinny nice and DC yeah
it's good when you're I think are you in
the middle or you're on the outside yeah
it goes yeah you Rogue in the middle
than DC on the inside yeah that's right
yeah
yeah so it's uh it's interesting though
no I mean I eat probably worse at home
on the road I eat cleaner whereas a lot
of people that I work with you know they
eat super clean and then when they come
on the road they just on the oats
because you like I'll go to Tampa uh
January 20th 21st so everyone's like oh
you gotta try this restaurant you gotta
do this all right let's do it it's in
New York the pizza you know you get
princess Pizza yeah yeah but see like I
don't like I don't eat [ __ ] baked
goods on the road but like if I'm home
like we have things that my kid like I
got blueberry muffins we have kids
so well uh let's let me feed you these
Bagels man we'll continue to decide
let's do it
but now I'm on my way stayed up every
single night and hustled every day
[Music]
no no no no no no
all right my man some some Beastie Boys
that's a play on Beastie Boys this is
taking me back to my childhood you know
a lot of good bagels in the Northeast oh
look at this you have some oh that's
just the straight even the even the
cream cheese one looks pretty fire Casey
sweared by him he's a New Jersey Boy so
he knows
Connecticut I thought you're a jersey I
think different of you now yeah he's got
that 203 cell phone
refuse to change it nice Bagel bro I
mean I can fly all the way out here
before you head to Brazil or where the
hell you're going or Ukraine I don't
know this is banging like I try not to
talk in superlatives when I eat and say
things like this is the best breakfast
sandwich I've ever had but bro There's
Something About This Bagel is it nice
I'm pretty excited for it something
about this Bagel is there uh back home
in Boston you got some go-to's in
Massachusetts yeah I haven't been there
you haven't gone back in a while well
you big time your family back home most
of them are gone okay sorry about that I
did I did take my kids to Fenway Park
Last Summer
top of the first inning five nothing
Blue Jays I turned to my daughter I'm
like this one's over she's like what do
you mean five nothing top of the first
inning but we're staged seven Innings
and uh was it over oh yeah they lost it
28 to five or something yeah that's the
pros yeah but no most of my family has
left Boston but I try to take my kids
back to sort of experience the city my
kids love New York and as a Boston guy
exactly so when we first moved to South
Florida they my daughters would like
shove the Miami Dolphins in my face
right because I'm a Patriots fan asking
for dolphins gear but now they're on the
right side asking for dolphins yeah
yeah right no I think uh there's a two
address right for a while like Tannehill
jerseys wherever oh that's right
but yeah but uh no I mean I don't miss
the cold but it is weird like raising
kids in South Florida like I never
thought I would be in Florida but I like
the sun I like is that all they know
like were they born in Florida or
somewhere else then you moved to Florida
so my first daughter actually so five
people in my immediate family all born
in different states New York
Massachusetts Connecticut Nevada Florida
so my first daughter was born in New
Haven Connecticut when I was at ESPN
then we moved to Vegas had my second
daughter in Vegas that's her claim to
fame because she's [ __ ] crazy and my
son was born in Florida so nice yeah so
um but yeah I mean I liked Vegas my wife
didn't like Vegas
she just didn't want to raise the girls
in vegas which I certainly understand
it's an acquired taste there's certain
there's certain good things about Vegas
same with Florida
my thing people like oh you know you you
align more with Florida you know the
taxes and you know they didn't lock down
like yeah sure for what I do like Miami
there's some energy there but there's
just no end the comedy scene stuff but
there's no there's not a ton of energy
like here even though how many clubs
there's a hustle here like you you
touched on La touchdown New York Boston
for that matter there's a hustle energy
which I like because that competitive
energy there's no pull for you to go
back to Denver though none zero I go
back then I feel like I'm in a country
western yeah yeah I'm just like oh it's
slow here man yeah so that yeah I mean I
feel that a little bit I kind of like
that you know I live in like West Boca
Raton not like in the belly of the Beast
we're like removed because I'm a little
bit of a of a homebody I mean I'm super
homeless yeah Boca Raton they call it
Heaven's wedding room right there's a
lot of older people yeah my manager Lex
is down there yeah yeah and obviously a
lot of pro Fighters down there but yeah
when I first moved down there and you go
to like CVS and it takes you 20 minutes
to get a pack of gum because everyone in
line is 78 years old that was an
adjustment for me yeah and it can be
depressing like my wife was like
everyone's [ __ ] dying down yeah you
know so but it's gotten younger and
obviously a lot of New Yorkers I mean
that's I guess my biggest complaint is
that I feel like I'm in New York South
and as a Boston guy I can't even root
for Chris Weidman you know like we don't
root for New York it's like until my
daughter start putting New York City
over it no it's dirty no well let's get
into some fighting here my man I feel
like uh
I can't remember you and it might be my
perspective on it but I I feel like it's
a lot of people's perspectives I can't
imagine
in any sport a rougher start to 2023
it's been the roughest time to be an MMA
fan right now like there's so many
deaths you have the Dana situation you
know so it's just right now like I feel
like the sport is like it's just it's in
a tough spot of course we're gonna get
out of it I just think UFC needs to
announce like a big like if they
announce Jon Jones Francis some huge
mega fight we're all gonna forget about
all this darkness and just get back to
business so then you start rolling out
the big fight announcers which I think
is going to happen I think you're right
I think certainly if we could somehow
announce Kamar Usman and Leon Edwards
right that event has already been
announced from March 18th but we don't
have confirmation that kimara is going
to be a part of it but you're right I
think a Jon Jones Francis zingano
announcement would be useful I think
just having our pay-per-view in Rio here
in short order is going to help things
but uh yeah man you know Stefan Bonner
was a good friend of mine and certainly
we were closer
10 years ago than we were at the time of
just passing but you know he was at my
wedding like he was a really devoted
friend and when I moved to Vegas you
know his family really sort of brought
us in there because he's the biggest guy
at the time right yeah um but it just
saddened me to such an extent getting
that text message on Christmas Eve
because you know I feel like for a lot
of guys they transition out of fighting
and their mental physical and emotional
challenges and I just think for him he
had a lot of all of those and just
couldn't necessarily turn that corner
and then when it looked like maybe he
was going to turn the corner started a
podcast had some momentum you know
passes away at work yeah he was just a
good guy and he got you know Andrew
Lee's sister passed away and then you
know Rumble Johnson not too long ago
which was a tough one so it's just like
all this hit right Phil beroni things
just like what so it's like with the
Barony stuff The Dana stuff I feel like
the sport finally got to the main stage
and we're viewed upon from the public
like an NFL MLB or NBA and then with
that stuff it sets us back yeah yeah and
as Dana said yesterday to the media
you know the people that might lose
respect for him are people that he
respects a great deal you know Fighters
and his colleagues and even the MMA
media he's close with a lot of those
people but uh it's sort of just walking
back into your reality you know there
was one time on a UFC broadcast we had
two fighters competing Andre Ewell and
Chris Gutierrez and the why for both of
those guys is their sons that they
aren't allowed to see right Andre Ewell
has a son who's 13 who he can't see and
Chris Gutierrez his son is younger and
he can't see him and I sort of
mistakenly I wish I could take it back
but I tied their two stories together on
live TV and I mentioned that they both
had been through like custody battles
with their kid and I'm sort of trying in
the middle of a round to explain that
this is two this is why these guys fight
they're both heavy-hearted right and not
a day of my life goes by where some UFC
fan doesn't reach out to me on Twitter
or Instagram and says something about
the custody business
well that's part of the narrative like
to me that's what makes MMA great it's
like boxing it for the longest when you
think about those you know the countdown
stuff like that like you'd be a random
Maxine dude I had no clue who he was
yeah and you see his backstory they show
him you know uh in somewhere in Juarez
Mexico and you see his family and he's
fighting for his kid or whatever and I'm
like oh I'm sold on the guy right with
MMA there's so many great stories and
you do such a good job telling that
story unfortunately that one might be
you know a little darker story but
that's still their story well right and
that was what my intention was I mean my
intentions were clear and they were good
did they come off the phraseology wasn't
good right the term custody battle and
I'm glad on a platform like this to be
able to discuss this a little bit the
term custody battle obviously Rings true
with a lot of people and there are a lot
of negative connotations because it's a
battle between former spouses in a lot
of situations but ultimately Chris
Gutierrez and Andre Ewell had both
talked about this publicly they had
talked about it with us right it's not
like you broke news and when Chris
Gutierrez wins the fight you know I
thought a little bit Vindicated because
he's crying in the octagon with Joe
Rogan and had I not mentioned it then
why is he crying he's crying because
he's being kept from his son so I just
felt like I I had good intentions but I
didn't put it particularly well but I
bring it up in the context of what Dana
White uh is dealing with or not even
what he's dealing with he put it upon
himself but it's like walking back into
your new life honestly you know like
when I got off the air that night and I
saw my mentions thousands right I've
never had more mentions getting off the
air people calling for my job
something triggering but when Ronda
Rousey lost to Holly Holm welcome to
your [ __ ] new life and even though
Kamar Usman and Israel alasanya have
handled those circumstances maybe better
than Rhonda did like for Kamara like
he's handled it beautifully but dude
welcome to your new life so it is it
let's take another little break chatting
with my boy John anik on this week's
food truck Diaries because it's a new
year and guess what my friends at on it
are Heller to give you the best step
afford to making the best year possible
with on its New Year all you all right
they got everything you need they're
giving you 20 off select supplements and
nutrition 10 softs like Fitness 50 off
digital items and also you get Alpha
Brain to support your focus it's the
number one nootropic on the planet all
right they've sold over a million
freaking bottles you get your money back
guaranteed you don't need to send back
the product keep it that's how much they
trust in Alpha Brain the number one
nootropic on the planet for training you
can do at home join the New Year all you
program on at six challenge a six week
workout and lifestyle program with 36k
in prize money up for grabs the
challenge helps you connect with others
in on it community so you can support
each other achieve your goals and make
Bank bro that's right so you get temps
off select Fitness 50 off digital items
all right that means Alpha Brain you get
all sorts of dope gifts man all right
with 20 off 10 off 50 Off streaming
Fitness stay at home do the streaming
Fitness get kettlebells steel Club Mason
is you got protein powders hemp powders
we got everything Warrior bars it's on
it the One-Stop shop to get your year
right it's 2023 let on it help you it's
on it.com slash FTD that's on it.com
slash FTD for food truck Diaries
audit.com FTD safe termsoft the entire
website but right now for limit time
only through January again that's 10 off
select Fitness 20 off supplements 50 off
digital items and they can sign up for
the on at six challenge an all New Year
all new you on it get you some on it.com
slash FTD this episode of food truck
Dives with John anik is also brought to
you by my friends at happy hippo the
world's best Kratom on the planet listen
they just dropped their new little
Kratom shop shot here it's the
butterscotch it tastes delicious it also
gets your brain fired up it's my
Limitless pill whatever I'm doing
podcasts Stand Up Radio TV doesn't
matter your boy's unhappy hippocratum
it's the only Kratom that I try trust
and if you don't like the high
concentrated shots like your boy they
got powder they got pills they got
gummies they got anything you need to
get that delicious Kratom into your body
that's Happy Hippo go to happyhippo.com
promo code is thick23 that's thick with
three C's
t-h-i-c-c-c 23 and you save 20 off the
best Kratom on the planet for Life use
that code as many times as you want [ __ ]
with your friends your family thick 23
thick with three C's you get the best
Kratom on the plant that's
happyhippo.com promo code thick23 for
reals let's get back to the program yeah
I think I think with Dana it's tough and
I struggle with it because obviously you
know I get a lot of hate online stuff
like that so when someone's going
through something I don't care if I
don't have any enemies I don't some
people might not like me I they're not
getting that back you know it takes the
power from so with Dana people always
think we have issues we don't that's in
the past he's doing good I'm doing good
if he called me as a case job we need
you to cover this you got it dude yeah
his job those kicks were fly I wear 13.
cool you can have them I don't care
right I have no animosity towards a guy
so when this stuff came a lot of people
in my mentions emails oh can't wait to
see your take on this finally can light
this guy up like oh you haven't been
paying attention I don't dog pile I
don't see anybody get canceled he has
Wife and Kids clearly his wife wife and
kids it's not what I do what I do know
is people make mistakes I know that for
a fact I have friends who've made some
mistakes and I believe in a comeback
story I also don't think one situation
at a senior frogs in Cancun or wherever
he was at defines Dana White but there
has to be some sort of repercussions
there 100 you can't put your hands on
your women even if they hit you first I
don't know I don't care but I just I I
didn't know how to kind of take it in I
didn't know how to digest I'm like oh
that's not good that's not good and part
of me is like I don't want to see like
people are calling for him to lose his
job I'm like that's not the answer yeah
that can't be the answer like and for
those of you asking uh for him to lose
his job I'm not saying put your hands on
women but you've never made a mistake
before yeah but I I don't vouch for him
or defend him and as he said don't
defend them there should be some
repercussions I think my biggest
takeaway from all of it and they're
gonna do what they want with Dana and I
have no control over that but what I do
think uh that my takeaway was how
powerful is Dana White I don't think
like you know some people like oh if
he's a black man he'd been canceled it's
not a black or white thing it's a power
thing yeah I think you know he's shows
you how powerful is with
you can tell you know Fox and he's been
they've been mum on it which I was
surprised especially in this current
climate but just shows you how powerful
he was like oh that and you know has
nothing to do with me he doesn't control
anything I do I was like oh wow that's
that's intense how proud for that guys
yeah I can't imagine
and I haven't gotten Rogan's take out
but you know you gotta be careful with
Rogan too right he comes from a family
if he's seen domestic violence his mom
being punched in the face so I'm sure he
feels a certain type of way about it but
you guys are so close to the flame I'm
not I'm all the way out here it has to
well you guys you have to wake up just
like oh damn no it's hard it's a lot
like you don't and I'm not even trying
to put you on a spot you don't have to
answer no you don't mean like we're boys
I love the [ __ ] out of you so it's like
I was even gonna bring it up it's just
it's it's the alpha in the room kind of
no and it's a tricky thing right yeah
play voice for the UFC it's like I don't
know what people necessarily want me to
do right so yeah we thought about on our
podcast maybe we'll read Dana's quotes
and then have a quick reaction you know
nobody's gonna defend a man putting a
hand on a woman in terms of the
punishment and the repercussion I don't
think a 60-day suspension solves
anything but certainly a philanthropic
individual like people don't understand
just how philanthropic Dana White is
like he doesn't publicize the good will
he does so I think for him trying to
affect change in that World whether it's
sitting down with people who have been
involved in those situations or making a
contribution to women who have dealt
with something like this like yes you
can affect change in that area but I do
believe that you know not unlike for me
with the custody battle thing really a
valuable lesson for me to learn that's
something I'm going to be dealing with
for the rest of my broadcasting career
well I mean bro we're three years ago to
my mentions right now like there's a
custody battle mentioned today you know
but that's but that's online like the
majority of people and you know on so on
your Twitter whatever they say if you
walk down the street one in ten people
on Twitter you know they're familiar
with it so that might be the narrative
on social media but when you walk down
the street trust me dude I have a good
read on this most people like holy [ __ ]
there's John egg the greatest you know
commentary in Combat Sports no one's
like man you remember that one time on
that undercard he talked about custody
never I think that's more of your own
thing than obviously online it's the
only thing that what are you going to
grab Johnnie for what are you going for
yeah well
I appreciate your support and you've had
my back for 15 years now and obviously
Rogan's public support certainly helps
me he called the Republicans
commentary well play-by-play guy
obviously Joe and I have different jobs
and that's lost on some people I'm not
an analyst right now so there's there's
play-by-play and then there's color
right Joe's more of the color but
obviously you know we worked together
for the first time in 2012 and now we've
been working together regularly for
almost seven years but to have his
approval like can you imagine what it's
like for my twin brother and my mom to
see Joe Rogan go on a podcast and call
me you know the greatest playback oh
it's like you being an author and Oprah
recommends your book on a book club and
it's like just some books well and he
said one of these things not for nothing
like during my contract negotiation it's
like [ __ ] man like thank you yeah like
what's up now but just send me an app
for your negotiation but you know I do
have a clause in my contract that they
can fire me without cause at any time
and that's sort of unique for sports
broadcasters like when I signed an ESPN
contract the whole deal is guaranteed oh
interesting I didn't know that but I'm
not fearful of losing my job but I
really do have my head to the pavement
like feeling like I have to earn at
every show because one thing I think we
all know about Dana White is that if I
have a few bad shows in a row like he
won't hesitate to get rid of me like I
need to earn things I can see well you
think I need to earn that seat yeah and
I think you got some leeway now well and
certainly having like you have some
nerve well having certainly having Joe's
support because the thing is like we
want Joe for the long term and it just
feels bigger and better when he's there
and that's the majority opinion and for
me there's just such a different Dynamic
when he is there and I want to make sure
he's happy so if he's happy and he's
enjoying this like with respect to Mike
Goldberg I feel like Joe Rogan has never
had more fun than he is having right now
and that's the key like it's really it's
the three of you like I like don't get
me wrong a business is one of my
favorites Cruz is great felder's
phenomenal I want to see Laura sanco up
there with you guys she's great but when
it's you three it's something special
it's so sweet you got Rogan right this
legend that you the best to do it you
have DC Hall first Hall of Famer like
one of the best ever do it but the the
chemistry between you guys I was relate
to the fight campaigns that Rogan
started I do them now because he can't
and that's with his Blessing so um with
the fight campaign those were so special
because it was friends so even though
Eddie's this Jiu Jitsu Mastermind he
started 10th Planet you know and beat
Gracie in this phenomenal brilliant mind
he's a huge conspiracy theorist and then
you have Rogan who's you know the guy
right you know you have me and then you
have talent it was this this perfect
yeah like relationship where man it just
works yeah so when it's you Rogan in DC
it's like I can sit back and you guys
kind of break the fourth wall where I
think the reason why you guys worked so
well together is people feel like
they're watching with their friends
that's why fight companions work that's
why podcasts work yeah just people think
they can feel they can relate to it it's
not so suit and tie right so it's the
real shape of the three of you together
like you get the three of you should
never break up you're like thank you
you're like the Beatles you should never
break well thank you and those guys
deserve a lot of credit and certainly
Daniel for his levity and his comedy I
just think he brings out the best
version of Joe I do feel like Joe is at
his best when Daniel is to his right but
no it means a lot you know obviously
there was a time when Dana talked about
this dream team and there were rumors
that you know Mario Lopez was going to
come in and you know here I am the
number two guy being elevated to the
number one guy and then I got to hear
about this dream team of which in theory
I'm not a part I feel like I've
distanced myself what was the Dream Team
I don't know was it Mario Lopez I don't
know I don't know what the dream team
was I don't think I was a part of it but
I feel like humbly I've distanced myself
from that conversation oh you're the
Dream Team dude with my you're Larry
Bird because you're from Boston you're
late bird Rogan's Jordan and then DC's
Magic Johnson there's no Dream Team
without the three of them thanks I feel
like I've just had to Lopez Isaiah
Thomas no one likes uh yeah you know but
you got to put up with them I just feel
like y'all listen to them in the hotel
room I just feel like I've just it
sounds trite but like I've stayed true
to like what got me to the dance which
is just hard work preparation and just
sort of tuning out the noise right and
you know Dana and I have never been in a
better place than we are right now but
he certainly rode me pretty good when I
started right he told me that there were
going to be a lot of people who just
fell off of my support bandwagon and he
was absolutely right about that he said
my haters were going to go through the
roof and initially that's exactly what
happened but he said we're not hiring
you to be Goldie or Joe we're hiring you
to be yourself yes
he had heard two voices call every UFC
fight for 15 20 years so then all of a
sudden kenflo and I were calling that
fight in Nashville and he's in the back
like that's an adjustment for him and
MMA fans around the world and I think
now 11 12 years in
I feel like oh there's comfortable dude
there's no UFC without John in it well
you're irreplaceable man you know this
well you know one thing that I've really
tried to focus on is like the
championship calls and the fight ending
calls you know I don't have a token
phrase that I go to I'm trying to
provide the historical soundtrack for
the biggest moments in UFC history and I
want those moments to be unique I never
know what the [ __ ] I'm gonna say
sometimes it comes out better than
others you know well if it's pre-planned
we can all smell it right like it'd be
well most people could the only time I
ever thought about something Demetrius
Johnson was chasing down something and
the word immortality I felt like I
wanted to work that into a call and I'll
never do that again
you know you're like delayed yeah but
you know yeah it was immortality
Rogan's like what right it's like dude
yeah yeah come on man you're forcing it
right but when yamahovich broke through
you know Poland your guy got it done
it's seven words that I think will
withstand the test of time I don't know
what the [ __ ] I was gonna say but
sometimes less is more you know even
saying like fourth round TKO if you
inflect the right way can be powerful
yeah and then one more sleep
speaking of which Brazil designs are out
this is a double Excel I think this is
our best design with the Brazilian flag
underneath I think this is some
Brazilian ties by Brazilian ties one
more sleep uh I had a good sleep in
Brazil when no gear knocked me out so
this is offensive but I appreciate the
shirt there you go so that's the double
blue cell and then we did bring you
um the New York City Edition
that's what we're talking about that's
those middle type that's a UFC Oh that's
81. oh that one's sick but that's a
little more subtle right yeah I dig it
though man so but one more sleep is kind
of your thing it's funny it sort of took
off organically as we filed the
trademark we had to go back and find my
first usage of it and it was like a
tweet in 2015 it sort of took on a life
of its own there is a Christmas song
called one more sleep but yeah it's sort
of
something I become associated with and
we're selling the merchandise and having
fun with it but um it doesn't look like
we're gonna get the trademark but yeah
it's kind of a cool thing yeah I love it
yeah now as far as looking forward to
Future fights is there any fights that
you're like you need to see happen this
year to me John has to fight Jon Jones
has to fight before you answer John just
has to fight
um I would love a a Suga and uh Al
Jermaine Sterling but Sterling just came
out and said he injured his shoulder
right so it's probably gonna be sahuto
and uh sugar which is good fight yeah
um you know I think volcanasi machev's
great fight yeah I'm trying to think who
else
um Izzy Pierre rematch yep gotta think
that that's gonna happen just hey
running from them give them give them
flat he he can't get a fight I don't
even see him on Instagram either it's
like dude this isn't helping you yeah
like he looks terrifying well and like
let's take below Muhammad right a guy
who love him and he's not going to turn
down Hamza shimaya but there are times
where maybe a fighter like Bilal will be
approached with a hamzat fight and he
just has beating Sean Brady and then
maybe they want him to turn around in
seven weeks but it's just not realistic
it's one thing to turn down hamzat she
may have when you're getting what
amounts to a full training campaign
that's another thing when the
circumstances intervene so I don't think
below turned down homsout if he was
offered that fight in a full training
camp like no [ __ ] I actually think
Blau as far as stylist he poses the most
issues for him yeah there's not a lot of
guys you see issues for Hamza so when we
did our year-end wrap up in 2020 my
dream fight was kamzachimaya versus Kobe
Covington and now two years later like
that's still my dream match up so I
would like to see that but the fight I
got to see this year is Valentina
shevchenko against John Wayne Lee it
doesn't seem as though chefchenko and
Nunes are going to fight a third time at
35 even though Valentina finally seems
to have redeveloped an appetite for that
fight but do Chong Wei Lee is someone
who can absolutely become a double
Champion her graph will look much better
I'll tell you who uh is gonna give
change a run for her money by the end of
the year it's Tatiana soyas that's right
she's coming back that's right she's a
problem and Suarez she has even hinted
that she wants to go back to strawwood
I'd like to see her stay at Flyway
Canada me too but she can do both yeah
but I I think to chase that chefchenko
she could get in stylistically for
injuries you know if her necks there
yeah she's a problem that's a great name
to inject into the conversation because
they need to have she's gonna fight
Montana De la Rosa and if she beats her
she could certainly fight Valentina it
looks like Talis Santos and Aaron
blanchfield are going to fight both of
them would be worthy even though Santos
already had her shot
um but I don't know man like I'm not so
sure Jean Wei Lee doesn't beat Valentina
chefchenko I know she just won the belt
for a second time so maybe there will be
a title defense first but uh but after
seeing Wei Lee like oh man she's gotten
way better oh no doubt no doubt it's
grappling the transitions or Jiu Jitsu
like oh this girl's a problem it's crazy
to look back to her two fights seriously
nuts you know for Conor McGregor too and
I'm changing gears a little bit here but
Conor's gonna fight again in the UFC
like you know he is a fighter he is a
mixer artist he'll fight this year and
this is what he wants to do like yeah
there's a monetary component to it but
there's no way for him to scratch the
competitive itch that he's trying to
scratch anywhere else but the octagon so
yeah the whiskey sales aren't doing it
for him like he did that right so I
think
for Connor I just think his team need to
sit down and go we know you want to
fight Monkey Joe we know you want to do
this Charles Oliver yeah you've been out
too long the game doesn't work like this
let's get a win get the fans back on
your side and then go for that big shot
and then maybe ride off into the sunset
but Tony Ferguson makes a lot of sense a
Chandler would be fun yeah the tough
Heights but to go straight to the tip of
the spare you know the kamaru usmans or
the you know the Charles oliveras or the
Macho it's like no no yeah you've been
out too long another loss and it's just
game against that match yeah I mean I'd
be surprised to see him back at 55
obviously he would only be back at 55
for the Undisputed lightweight
Championship what about mosquito is that
oh wow that does it for me yeah that
does oh that's interesting at
welterweight you know and maybe there
would be more upside to that matchup for
Connor than than a Ferguson fight 55 is
gonna be tough for him yeah she's too
juicy in a good way like he's Jack yeah
but no I mean it's interesting because
in terms of superstars like the biggest
thing that I am charged with is
humanized our athletes and help in the
promotion create stars and it's always
fun to me when people say like dude like
yeah there's never going to be another
Conor McGregor right like Patty pimlet
is a star but like nobody's gonna reach
Conor's level I feel pretty convicted in
saying that notion that there aren't
going to be other stars right like dude
I remember in 2017 we were having this
conversation and then Israel adasanya
goes on to headline like 25 percent of
our pay-per-views for the next four
years and then Patty pimlet and Alex
padetta on and on it goes so Sean these
guys coming out of nowhere so there's
all it's always going to be there it's
always going to be there you just don't
know who it's going to be I do think
yeah as far as like those big
pay-per-view Stars it's just it it's a
different business model now yeah the
the Conor days of those huge
pay-per-view uh Superstars are gone I
think now your biggest pay-per-view
Stars probably Izzy yeah you know but
like last year was like a good year for
the hardcores right like pay-per-views
like Charles Oliveira versus Islam
akashev right but like for me like do I
get more excited for Charles Oliveira
versus Islam akashev or the BMF title
fight right like to me we've had a lot
of highly competitive highly compelling
matchups between the best fighters in
the world that maybe aren't doing north
of 300 000. if you buy it and I don't
care right
yeah agree I agree now as far as your
boy Kenny Florin what we can end on this
fuzzy boy Kenny Florian Jake Paul signed
with pfl when I heard that you know
Kenny's our boy I was like oh this is
good for Kenny because bfl you know it's
a good lead it's uh you know it's in
cahoots with ESPN UFC so it's good
league but Jake Paul going there it's
it's gonna be so beneficial for our boy
Kenny and I'm interested to see who does
Jake Paul fight MMA because if I'm his
manager before you answer if I'm his
manager we go for Nate Diaz but you box
first right I do believe he has a chance
to beat Nate in boxing yeah you're not
going to beat Nate and MMA so I think
you do the box match first hopefully you
win that if you're Jake team Jake then
you go to MMA that could be a little
more difficult for you but then there's
the paydays on that trilogy match yeah
whichever is boxer it depends you know
so hanato moykano came out and said he
feels like Jake Paul has a far easier
time beating Nate Diaz in a boxing
setting than Nate Diaz has beating Jake
Paul in an MMA setting like when you
forecast Nate mopping the floor with
Jake Paul who has some size on him like
how is that going down because certainly
I think Nate would be a three to one
favorite over Jake Paul but like dude
there's a huge size discrepancies still
in power I mean standing Guillotine like
you got to get the fight to the floor
and Nate's not known for his wrestling
Jake has some wrestling background in
high school which you know I always hate
saying High School background but uh he
does have a little more experience when
it comes to wrestling yeah so if they
couldn't take him down it could it could
be some some issues you know I don't
think I've seen yeah three to one you
know Jeremy Stevens Anthony Showtime
Pettis other big names that are under
that piece as well Banner but too small
right but I just have to say man like I
don't know if you saw that whole six
minute promotional video that Jake Paul
put out there obviously for me like I
didn't love the sort of veiled shot at
Dana my boss at the end but dude I
thought it was [ __ ] brilliant I
thought it was masterfully produced he's
a great orator and an articulator
putting over the rest of the pfl roster
like I really thought
that in terms of like a directive for
fans like it was [ __ ] perfect he's
interesting to see because you know you
talk about hey who has more hate Than
Jake Pollock Jake and his brother you
know a lot of fans a lot of hate right
it goes hand in hand if you're doing
something well you can have haters so
those guys have so much hate and
especially when Jake and Logan for that
matter but really more so Jake when he
came over to the boxing scene now he's
coming to MMA the MMA fight scene hated
that yeah yeah but it's crazy for me to
see he's like he's kind of winning
people over fighter pay now he's willing
to risk it and fight MMA it's hard to
hate on the guy it's like okay yeah all
right well
50 split on pay-per-view it's like this
is unheard of and we'll see right how
that all plays out because that business
model is not sustainable right and if
you think about let's just say Jeremy
Stevens versus Jake Paul right how does
that do on pay-per-view right because
ultimately 50 of what right like you
still got to get people to actually
purchase the pay-per-view and I think
for Jake too coming over pfl a lot of
people you know aren't doing to this but
a big problem for Jake on his fights
that were on Showtime and wherever else
he was fighting a lot of that was
pirated like a lot of his fan base that
younger fan base they're not paying
right 50 60 whatever right they're
illegally streaming that thing so his
numbers that might show whatever five
hundred thousand six hundred thousand
really it's like 1.5 probably 2 million
because that young fan base is stealing
it yeah no you come over to ESPN good
luck stealing that bad boy you can don't
get me wrong but the majority of those
youngsters aren't gonna be able to steal
it so that's another benefit for him you
know coming over to this kind of Empire
you're not gonna be able to steal it as
much no I think it's important that you
got that out there I will say though and
I'm talking to someone right now who's
built a [ __ ] Empire for himself in
Southern California and a lot of it's
rooted in hard work right obviously you
have a lot of natural Talent comedic
ability and timing and all that [ __ ]
right but Jake Paul's a [ __ ] worker
like why does he have my ultimate
respect like you don't think there are a
hundred or so fighters on our roster
that Jake Paul is working harder than
like this dude works so to me
unless I'm missing something like my
respect for him initially was just
rooted in the fact that that he worked
that's where I came from and people when
I co-signed him and Logan who I know
both of them pretty well Logan used to
live very close to me so me and him
became friends
but originally you know they're I'm too
old to I've never I've never seen any of
their YouTube videos right I think I saw
the Logan Paul in the the forest when we
got in trouble for I was like this is
insane I can't believe people watch this
but they do yeah so I wasn't a fan of
like his work in that sense but then
when I started coming around like oh
these guys they know exactly what
they're doing not only are they business
savvy but they're working their ass off
and then when I went to watch Jake work
out I'm like oh this dude is put in work
and then when you think about it him and
his brother are so massive as far as
their fan base they could play checkers
and make millions of dollars they
decided to do boxing and MMA are you out
of your mind right yeah they are yeah
but it's just good luck to you I don't
hate on it and I also feel like for Jake
like when you look at that early footage
like he wanted to be an MMA fighter more
than a boxer correct and obviously it's
a harder sport to realize long-term
success in right I mean certainly you
can argue especially with respect for
for women right like if you want to
become a professional athlete like mixed
martial arts is probably sport like you
can get on a path where you can't
necessarily get on that path to get to
the WNBA as easily you know but um I
think yeah I just yeah it's interesting
I think too where what really opened my
eyes and this is just insane it's just a
story about Logan Paul so I worked the
Logan Paul Floyd Mayweather fight I was
the expert on Logan Paul right that's
right and so I'd go into his locker room
and I and you know I've known Logan a
while now in my head I'm like I'm gonna
go back to somebody [ __ ] show I wish I
was in Floyd's luckily it was gonna be
way more calmer I go into like you're up
and I go into Logan Paul's locker room
I'm like trying to hide myself I'm like
just be calm talk them down if he's
freaking out I go back at I go back
there
they're playing like weird like Yogi
music there's like incense and you would
have thought they were doing you know a
hot yoga session really it was the
calmest locker room I've ever seen wow
and I go up to him he's not nervous at
all he's like laughing with his friends
and stuff and they're wrapping his hands
and I was like you don't see me ever saw
he's like no I've already won he's like
dude I'm a YouTuber and as he's riding
his hands he goes I'm a YouTuber dude he
goes I'm about he was I'm 30 minutes
away from fighting Floyd Mayweather goes
you know how stupid this is and I was
like oh my God his dad's freaking out
though right and so I grew up to his dad
and he's like man what are you think and
I go I go pops listen your son's way
bigger than him right worst thing that's
gonna happen is Floyd hits when the body
shot he goes down yeah trust me he's
gonna be fine he's too big for him and
he goes you think he's gonna win I know
it's like you're crazy but he's not
going to get like taken on a stretcher
Floyd's small and I saw Floyd hitting
mitts and he had like this Gray beard he
said man I was like oh he looks that's
because I've worked with Floyd before
I'm like oh he looks he looks his age I
was like
Logan might be able to do something he's
not going to beat him but he might be
able to win some rounds you know but
just seeing I'm like these guys are on a
different level dude just a different
planet in terms of your nerves before
Big Time college football games versus
fights nice close so nothing for the
football game like just wrestling no
heart rate like nervous and and I was
thinking about because you know those
were the days you know we played in the
Texas when the powerhouses when they had
you know
um uh what's his freaking name um Vince
Young yeah the Vince Young Young boss
gave
um and then you escape both gave amazing
tight end playing Oklahoma against Jason
White Heisman Trophy when that time
Adrian Peterson at the time but then
their defenses Derek Johnson so I would
have to go against certain guys so I was
nervous about the single guy and you
know performing what I was supposed to
do on certain plays but nothing yeah
nothing like the UFC right listen great
sport love to watch it worst gig in the
world Dude where's [ __ ] gig dude I
was terrified terrified and I I listen
I'm very open about people like Yo [ __ ]
cool I'm telling you I've been back
there the toughest people you know that
you guys love I've seen them [ __ ] in
their pants oh yeah I've seen world
champions their coaches be like you're
going out there yeah and like nope I'm
not doing tonight he's like you're going
out there crying yeah so I wasn't that
bad right I'm just not that big of a
[ __ ] I can admit it I'm like yes it's a
tough gig man also ignorance is bliss
those guys are like hell yeah another
day in the office I'm like oh you're
stupid but you did you kept going back
to the well didn't have options wow as
soon as I as soon as I saw that crack
open for podcasts and comedy I was like
see ya and it is interesting for a lot
of football players because the dream
can end quickly man like all of a sudden
you don't make the NFL and it's just
hard to like build yourself back up and
that can be a tough transition like John
Volante thought without a shadow of a
[ __ ] doubt that he was going to be in
the NFL me too I thought I was gonna be
Tony Gonzalez yeah and then you got that
me too yeah then I got to the Buffalo
Bills a lot excuse me nowhere else set
on slow white guys I was like oh yeah
that makes sense I'm gonna get my [ __ ]
and go like yeah thank you oh you've
worked 20 years to bring your dream
since you're a kid I'm like yeah like we
don't give a [ __ ] here's a hat I'm like
thank you thank you yeah it's
heartbreaking man heartbreaking that's
interesting Pro Sports yeah yeah
but uh yeah do you root for the bills
because of that experience or no
um I feel like it's kind of cheesy to
root for him because I literally I
played as many games for the bills as
you did but I did go to camp with them
you know but um they invited you to Camp
they did and at one point they were
still in my jersey which is interesting
but um that's cool I mean I would rock
I'm a Patriots I would wear a [ __ ]
shop yeah yeah for sure give me
royalties on that but
um uh and it was way after the fact it's
like five years ago but um yeah there's
something weird I root for him yeah
then I I get it but uh before you go
dude so for every guest I'm a
sneakerhead you know this you were this
Rodriguez who does that so uh my boys at
suplex in Philly East Coast uh crew I
was they they supply all the shoes for
the guys and I always pick out a shoe
that's why I asked you shoe size and
they're like oh should we send this I'm
like no dude you're talking about a
legend we gotta get a legendary shoe so
to me this is the the best silhouette of
all time it's a legend shoe for a legend
dude these are for you
I may not be lying if I said I flew out
here just for for the for the shoes but
it's kind of yeah
yeah
and I didn't want to do too flashy I
don't want to do like oh and the pink
laces are going in yeah you got to do
pink places yeah see I was gonna put
those in Daddy thank you and see what
they said these are right up my alley
and when you see me here they're not too
they're not too crazy so you could wear
them that fit you don't like fly as [ __ ]
when you see me emceeing the weigh-in
and real Little Rock does I'll be
wearing it and we're gonna post a
picture like [ __ ] shop so this is Mr
hammock first and foremost huge fans
here at suplex Seekers please wear and
enjoy these Jordan Ones we had to lace
the goat with some sneakers they called
you to go through some sneaks from the
goat uh if you're ever in Philly stop by
and see us on South Street suplex thank
you unbelievable thank you thank you
guys I'm gonna come see in Philadelphia
man thank you for having me out I know
it's been a hot second dude you're the
businessman in sports so you know we
finally got it done I love you man keep
crushing it thank you man you do the
same man keep the empire
[Music]